monsieur le ministre je vous souhaite la
bienvenue je vous remercie de vous être
rendu disponible pour répondre à nos
questions dans cette salle que vous
connaissez bien nous avons entamé en
février les travaux de notre commission
enquête sur les révélations des uber
fight ubérisations sur lobbying et ses
conséquences vous le savez à partir du
10 juillet 2022 plusieurs membres du
consortium international du journalisme
on publie ce qui est désormais convenu
d'appeler les uber-files s'appuyant sur
124000 documents internes à l'entreprise
américaine datée de 2013 à 2017 cette
enquête a dénoncé un lobbying agressive
de la société uber pour implanter en
France comme dans de nombreux pays des
véhicules transports et que chauffeurs
des VTC venant concurrencer le secteur
traditionnel du transport public
particulier de personnes réservées
jusqu'alors au taxi dans ce contexte
notre commission d'enquête à deux
objectifs d'une part identifier
l'ensemble des actions de lobbying
menées par uber le rôle des décideurs
publics de l'époque et émettent des
recommandations sur l'encadrement des
relations entre décideurs publics et
représentants d'intérêt d'autre part
évaluer les conséquences économiques
sociales environnementales du
développement du modèle ur en France
l'ubérisation et les réponses apportées
et à apporter par les décideurs publics
en la matière la mesure vous avez été
nommée secrétaire d'état chargé et
transports à l'époque du conflit entre
les taxis et VTC en 2014 après l'arrivée
du beurre sur le marché français vous
avez participé à aller le laboration des
lois techno puis grand Guillaume pour
résoudre ce conflit il nous est apparu
essentielle de recueillir votre
témoignage et d'une manière générale
nous souhaitons connaître votre
appréciation des révélations des
uberfalls et de l'implantation de la
société
uber en France et des VTC en France
je vais vous laisser vous exprimer
puisque on a pris un peu de retard donc
je vais faire très bref vous avez vu les
débats qui ont animé notre commission
d'enquête l'équilibre à trouver entre
l'accompagnement des news acteurs la
place laisser à la croissance et
l'innovation et bien sûr le respect du
droit de l'ordre public et la protection
d'une profession réglementée qui était
celle des taxis nous venons à l'instant
d'auditionner le premier disque monsieur
Cazeneuve qui nous a dit qu'il n'y avait
pas eu de Deal comme ça rapporté par la
presse entre le gouvernement et
uber au sujet de l'harmonisation des
conditions d'accès à la formation et à
profession des chauffeurs de taxi et de
VTC je voudrais donc vous interroger sur
votre perspective sur les révélations
des uberphales sur votre rôle à l'époque
et les différents éléments notamment que
je viens de mentionner qui est fait
l'objet d'une couverture médiatique
conséquente je rappelle que cette
audition est ouverte à la presse qui est
retransmis en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale et avant de vous
laisser la parole je vous rappelle que
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires à cause de
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
de la vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vais donc vous inviter
monsieur le ministre à activer votre
micro lever la main droite et dire je le
jure je te jure merci je vous laisse la
parole
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs la
société Hubert s'est installée en France
avec la certitude que la révolution dans
le transport particulier de personnes
qu'elle proposait justifier
la méthode du passage en force et le
risque assumé d'un conflit juridique
permanent exacerbé
mais cette stratégie n'est pas
spécifique à la France
elle a été appliquée partout dans toutes
les métropoles et d'une manière
systématique en France pour parvenir
assez fins la société Hubert a des mis
en service Hubert système aberrant
chaque citoyen devenait lui-même
potentiellement un chauffeur à ses
heures perdues et à utiliser ce qui
était plus sophistiqué le cadre
juridique loti
qui permettait le recrutement de
chauffeur avec un simple permis B c'est
là la fraude massive de Hubert en France
au départ en plus de Hubert pop il a été
mis fin au système Hubert pop j'y
revienne pas et le contournement de la
Loti a été rendu impossible par un
dispositif législatif et le gouvernement
pendant cette période gouvernement
auquel j'ai appartenu j'avais été
précédemment ministre des Relations avec
le Parlement et porter la loi sur la
transparence ce qui me permet d'avoir
aussi cette vision des choses le
gouvernement a été soumis à un double
conflit le conflit entre les taxis et
les VTC mais aussi en parallèle le
conflit entre les chauffeurs VTC et
Hubert et il fallait gérer parfois en
même temps c'est deux approches
et l'opinion publique dans cette période
on remonte ici il y a pratiquement 10
ans l'opinion publique était très
favorable à Hubert
il y avait un véritable succès chez les
utilisateurs
rencontré plus de gens qui prenaient
Hubert que dans des gens qui avaient une
opinion défavorable
Hubert recrutait des milliers de
chauffeurs
dans les banlieues et notamment par
exemple en Seine-Saint-Denis je rappelle
que le service public de l'emploi
que j'avais interrogé à l'époque
participait directement à ces opérations
de recrutement
aux côtés de Hubert dans une période où
je résume un peu mais c'était ça
dans le débat public
l'objectif principal le débat c'était
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage
c'était ça la question qui était partout
dans la presse et évidemment ça explique
aussi les réactions dans cette période
l'opinion publique les experts
économiques
donc je sais aujourd'hui que certains
étaient rémunérés mais à l'époque je
lisais avec intérêt parfois et froid
leurs explications sur finalement la
victoire à venir du nouveau monde celui
de la dérèglementation sur l'ancien
monde autrement dit celui que j'ai
incarné en fait dans le gouvernement
celui du respect du droit de travail
mais aussi des règles spécifiques au
chauffeur de taxi
le ministère des Transports au départ
dans ce conflit il n'avait aucune
compétence puisque
pour des raisons historiques on va dire
les choses comme ça
les taxis étaient rattachés au ministère
de l'Intérieur
et peut-être comme moment où les
obligations en matière de renseignements
passés par d'autres réseaux je n'avais
plus cette nécessité donc le ministère
de l'Intérieur à un moment donné Bernard
Cazeneuve que vous avez
auditionné à choisi de regrouper les
compétences et de me transférer ses
compétences pour qu'on puisse traiter
l'ensemble du dossier VTC taxi puisque
nous étions pour partie chargés des VTC
et tourisme que les VTC je dirais
nouvelle génération ont été plus ou
moins rattachés au numérique donc à
Emmanuel Macron et des taxis à
l'intérieur donc je j'ai eu la charge
d'harmoniser tout cela
dans un gouvernement où il y avait deux
lignes
c'est clairement
identifié et exprimer la ligne défendue
par Emmanuel Macron et la ligne que je
défendais avec
Bernard Cazeneuve
pour être très précis Emmanuel Macron ne
cachait pas ses convictions
elle nourrissait régulièrement nos débat
puisque ministre des Transports était
aminéaire rencontré très régulièrement
séance de travail en commun le ministre
de l'économie mais
les positions que je défendais
ont toujours reçu un arbitrage favorable
de la part du Premier ministre et de la
majorité de l'Assemblée nationale
les lois thévenus les lois
grand-guillaume je crois apporter des
réponses utiles et efficaces
sur le fond on termine par là
l'émergence des plateformes de ce modèle
de réservation moi me pose pas de
problème en tant que tel c'est pas de
réticence à l'évolution technologique
ce qui me pose un problème c'est le
modèle social qui est choisi c'est à
dire un modèle et qui crée des
travailleurs précaires et je regrette
vraiment que dans cette période nous
n'ayons pas su rappeler dans ce débat ou
l'opinion publique était sans inverse
très favorable Albert que le salariat
était une conquête
le salariat historiquement c'est une
conquête pour répondre à la précarité
des tâcherons
et que finalement
ce soi-disant nouveau monde de vendre
aux yeux était en train de réinventer
des recettes sociales qui finalement
appartenaient au monde très ancien
la question de la présomption de
salariat évoque votre commission reste
aujourd'hui d'actualité et pour être
très clair je souhaite vivement que le
gouvernement français
exprime une position en fin de soutien à
l'initiative européenne
le travail de votre commission mais
également un exergue la question de la
transparence
des relations entre les responsables
publics et les représentants d'intérêts
privés
les propositions faites par le président
Didier Migaud lors de son audition me
paraissent pertinente
il convient probablement d'y ajouter une
réponse particulière sur la traçabilité
des amendements
à mon sens je veux conclure par cette
phrase
les révélations des hubert-fight n'ont
pas eu de conséquences pratiques
dans la période où j'exerçais mes
responsabilités ministérielles mais
manifestement elles interrogent sur la
question de la transparence des
pratiques gouvernementales je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre et merci
aussi pour vos recommandations à la fois
sur les directives européennes et sur
les règles de transparence qui sont
effectivement deux aspects majeurs de
notre commission d'enquête pour revenir
sur les débats de l'époque
est-ce que vous pouvez nous décrire les
forces en présence des débats au sein du
gouvernement j'entends
lors de l'examen des lois TV nous et
grand Guillaume les positions le Premier
ministre a évoqué il savait déjà été
évoqué d'ailleurs dans la semaine
précédente
position du ministère de l'Intérieur qui
traditionnellement quel que soit le
ministre a plutôt tendance à être proche
de la question de la réglementation des
protection des taxis et de l'ordre
public tandis que le ministère de
l'Économie là aussi quel que soit le
ministre je monte beaucoup
favorise plutôt l'innovation la
croissance l'accompagnement des acteurs
technologiques est-ce que c'est votre
votre sentiment est-ce que ce débat
selon vous a été conduit dans dans la
transparence dans le débat inter
ministériel le Premier ministre vient de
nous dire que aucune décision de cette
époque n'a échappé à la transparence du
débat interministériel ou des avis vifs
et contradictoires pouvaient s'exprimer
mais sans opacité aux dissimulations
sur le terrain des conséquences
pratiques oui c'est-à-dire que toutes
les décisions qui avaient été prises en
interministériel ont été respectées sur
le fond sur la forme il y a eu quelques
quelques dérives
je dirais quelques assouplissements à la
règle commune
il n'est pas normal
dans une majorité mais il y avait
malheureusement d'autres exemples à
l'époque que certains s'exonèrent des
décisions collectives qui avaient été
prises et des amendements parlementaires
qui ne correspondent pas aux arbitrages
qui avaient été rendus soit à
l'intérieur du groupe majoritaire
d'ailleurs supposé qu'il y ait des
règles ou à l'intérieur du gouvernement
qui arrive
comme cela déposé par un député
dont on connaissait finalement
l'origine ou qu'on soupçonnait qu'il y
avait une inspiration forte derrière les
amendements Bello que j'ai vu arriver
comme cela alors qu'il ne suivait pas
officiellement ces textes ou ceux de
caresses que vous allez je crois
entendre tout cela c'était quand même je
dirais au niveau des pratiques ce
n'était pas ce qu'il y avait de plus de
plus exceptionnel mais ça n'a jamais eu
aucune conséquence puisque le
gouvernement de toute façon les
décisions gouvernementales
négative sur tel ou tel aspect ou tel
est à l'amendement ont toujours été
respectée il n'y a jamais eu de remise
en cause des décisions qui avaient été
prises dans les réunions
interministérielles auxquelles moi je
participe tout le temps et sur lesquels
le rapport de force était celui que vous
avez évoqué c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait
effectivement d'un côté l'intérieur
soutenez massivement la question des
taxis et moi aussi mais aussi la
question sociale voilà et puis l'autre
côté le ministère de l'économie
merci je voudrais sur la question de
l'arrêter du 2 février 2016 puisque
c'est quelque chose qui vous qui vous
préoccupe et qui m'a préoccupé quand
j'ai entendu vos débats je me suis dit
mais qu'est-ce qu'on a fait qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette affaire bon ce
serait fait avoir d'une certaine façon
puisque c'est ce que vous voulez nous
expliquer je veux m'inscrire en faux
parce que je pense qu'il y a une erreur
dans l'appréciation qui a été faite par
les journalistes au départ sur la portée
de cet arrêté et sur ce qu'elle a pensé
y compris uber et je vais vous donner
quelques quelques éléments d'abord c'est
arrêté il est signé par qui
pour aller jusqu'au bout du raisonnement
il est signé par des fonctionnaires par
délégation 1 de mon ministère un du
ministère de Bernard Cazeneuve et le
troisième par le ministère une personne
que vous avez d'ailleurs entendu de la
direction de la concurrence à la
consommation ça supposerait donc
que nous étions en termes pénal on
dirait pas qu'on puisse mais qu'en
hauteur de la démarche donc je
réussiemment accepté quelque chose qui
allait dans le sens total de ce que je
défendais et qui me valait je dirais une
certaine suspicion de la part de la part
de Hubert pour qu'ils ce n'était pas un
interlocuteur facile
première question deuxièmement
si c'est arrêté si ce dit il existait
avec les conséquences que vous craignez
est-ce qu'il s'est manifesté dans les
chiffres
et est-ce que vous avez un nombre de VTC
puisque l'idée qui est défendue c'est de
dire on aurait facilité en passant de
250 à 7h de formation l'accès des VTC
donc le résultat c'est que on aurait dû
immédiatement avoir une multiplication
des du nombre de licences
alors je vous laisse faire les
recherches le résultat est exactement
l'inverse exactement
et donc je suis allé plus loin je me
suis dit mais enfin
peut-être qu'on s'est trompé
et quel a été la réaction de Hubert à
s'est arrêté parce que c'est ça le fond
de la faire
s'est arrêté il parle des secteurs et on
dit ça a éliminé les 250 heures alors je
vais être très clair il y avait aucun
texte et il y avait les 250 heures qui
étaient fournis par qui
et contrôlé par qui
il y avait un marché au noir qui
fonctionnait avec aucune aucun contrôle
par personne c'était l'opinion de
l'administration ni les moyens de le
faire
l'arrêté il fait quoi il change
radicalement le système c'est plus la
formation qui compte c'est l'examen
comment on peut nous reprocher du
laxisme ou un deal alors que en remplace
une formation qui était suspecte pour
tout le monde par un examen
la lecture du texte du contenu de
l'examen est quand même assez
forte vous le vous l'avez lu c'est toute
une série d'épreuves avec un contenu
assez costaud au point que
c'est là que j'en viens je me suis dit
mais qu'est-ce qui avait été la réaction
de
peut-être qu'on leur a fait un cadeau
sans le savoir il y a pas eu beaucoup de
réactions il y en a une mais très longue
et très détaillée qui est dans un
article publié dans une revue que je ne
connaissais pas qui s'appelle l'usine
digitale et qui est un très long
interview du patron de Hubert
qui
est très intéressant puisqu'il y a là
toute qu'il me passe l'expression la
logorrhée de l'idéologie du Berre
pendant 4 ou 5 pages sur on va changer
le monde etc etc mais peu importe ça
vous le retrouverez vous connaissez mais
il réagit dans cette interview qui est
publiée après le décret c'est-à-dire au
mois de juin 2016 et
quand on lui pose la question de savoir
ce qui se passe
il dit ceci
la préoccupation des gens qui nous
contactent c'est lui qui parle ce n'est
malheureusement pas comment je fais pour
avoir une assurance accident du travail
mais tout simplement comment je fais
pour pouvoir travailler et devenir
chauffeur aujourd'hui des centaines
d'inspirants chauffeurs sont sur la
liste d'attente en raison de l'examen
qui a été mise en place pendant trois
mois par en juin pendant trois mois de
janvier à mars ils ont attendu réviser
et en avril l'examen est enfin arrivé et
le taux de réussite fut élevé
85% les taxis ont râlé en mai pour le
deuxième examen l'administration a revu
les questions durci l'épreuve d'anglais
émis Camus
dans l'épreuve de français le taux de
réussite est tombé à 25 % et la liste
d'attentes s'allonge soyons clairs c'est
toujours l'équipe j'adore la peste de
canule est en mieux si beaucoup de gens
le lisent mais c'est vraiment une
compétence indispensable pour conduire
je vous passe la suite pour pas être
trop long donc c'est ça la réponse du
maire et c'est ce qui s'est passé et moi
j'ai vécu cela et je me souviens très
bien de ce qui s'est passé au moment du
contenu des de l'arrêté de l'examen
effectivement
l'examen a été modifié parce que tout le
monde était très vigilant les taxis
suspectés que l'examen soit trop facile
pour Hubert Hubert suspecté que l'examen
soit trop dur pour les empêcher d'avoir
des licences mais la bataille elle était
bien sur le contenu de l'examen et je ne
pense pas que l'on puisse continuer à
penser que il y a eu du laxisme dans cet
arrêté alors que d'abord il a été signé
par des gens dans la position était pas
celle-là et puis qu'on ne sait
aujourd'hui que statistiquement personne
pourra en prouver les conséquences et
que c'est exactement l'inverse à travers
ce que je viens de vous dire et que je
mettrai à votre disposition mais je
suppose que vous avez déjà peut-être
retrouver cette cet article dans vos
dans vos dans vos recherches
documentaires mais il est extrêmement
intéressant
donc pour être très clair
c'est arrêté qui effectivement a fait
l'objet d'une couverture médiatique
importante pour pour un arrêté
ni l'objet d'un deal avec Hubert et il
n'est même pas favorable en fait à
uber particulièrement
que je viens de vous lire la réaction du
Berte c'est-à-dire que les gens qui ont
réagi contre le contenu de cet arrêté
donc je rappelle que la question
principale c'est la création de l'examen
et sur le contenu de ces épreuves
puisque c'était la première fois toute
une série d'épreuves de sécurité
routière des épreuves de langue des
épreuves de conduite etc ils sont toutes
ces épreuves il va y avoir une
discussion il va y avoir d'ailleurs deux
arrêtés qui seront pris successivement
mais Hubert sera
je dirais très réactif contre ces
arrêtés et non pas pour applaudir la
parution de cet arrêté merci juste une
dernière question je voulais vous
interroger sur le bilan de toute cette
action des pouvoirs publics en 2017 à la
fin du mandat
nous avons entendu le lanceur d'alerte
très critique évidemment sur les
pratiques du beurre mais qui en même
temps dit qu'au fond toutes les lois
successives ont été un peu une sorte de
douche froide pour pour Hubert qui est
en fait
le statut des VTC en France à l'inverse
les représentants des taxis G7
considérant qu'on avait trouvé plutôt un
bon équilibre à la fin de ces différents
choix quel regard vous portez sur
l'équilibre entre VTC taxi entre
l'innovation l'accompagnement de
nouveaux acteurs et la protection
sociale le droit et la régulation à la
fin de cet effort en 2017
je crois que si on prend un peu de
distance par rapport à la gestion de ces
situations de Christ c'est vrai qu'on
était confrontés à un problème qui
aurait pu trouver d'autres solutions
puisque nous avions d'une part une
profession réglementée qui au surplus
avait une à qui une valeur patrimoniale
le jour où Charles Pasqua a décidé qu'on
pouvait vendre les licences des licences
de taxi avec des gens donc qui
subissaient cette situation y compris
dans leur dans leur patrimoine
l'émergence d'un service qui était
appréciée de la population il faut le
dire par rapport à un service de taxi
qui n'était pas finalement
totalement
apprécié avant l'arrivée l'arrivée des
VTC il aurait pu y avoir d'autres
solutions je n'étais pas fermé moi
intellectuellement à l'idée de d'une
fusion des professions y compris à la
question de l'indemnisation puisque
quand on m'a confié ce dossier je
l'avais mis dans la feuille de route
pour interroger notamment les taxis je
aucun succès d'estime par rapport à
cette à cette proposition mais il me
semblait que ce qui avait été fait
historiquement l'état elle a eu fait
quand on a fusionné les professions
d'avouer d'avocats au niveau des
tribunaux de grande instance dans les
années 70 ou même au niveau des cours
d'appels plus récemment il y a eu une
analysation du patrimoine de ce qui
était propriétaire de leur charge reste
la question de l'origine des formes il
n'a jamais été question pour moi que ce
soit avec des fonds publics mais on
aurait très bien pu comme ça a été fait
avec une partie des frais de justice
avoir quelque chose qui venait alimenter
un fond pour cette indemnisation mais on
peut aussi comprendre que les chauffeurs
de taxi il y avait cette valeur
patrimoniale qui est lié à leur avenir à
leur retraite préférer conserver
conserver ce système donc cette option
c'est fermé restez la régulation elle
est aujourd'hui me semble-t-il
assez pertinente
à condition que les règles soient
respectées c'est ça quand même la
question les moyens de contrôle
aujourd'hui
sur ce sujet et sur un sujet
qui n'est pas dans l'objet de votre
commission mais quand même je veux dire
tout le monde sait aujourd'hui que le
travail que l'on destin en la matière
c'est-à-dire la ni VTC ni taxi et la
captation d'une partie de la clientèle
touristique qui arrive à Roissy ne fait
pas honneur à la France aujourd'hui et
que du point de vue de l'État
déjà dans un premier temps renforcement
très fort des contrôles sur des
pratiques qui se passent aux vues
au-dessus de tout le monde serait me
semble-t-il une amélioration de la
situation de la même façon que sur le
nom respect de tel ou telle règle sur la
question de l'occupation du domaine
public ce qui fait la séparation des
activités VTC et taxi il y a aussi me
semble-t-il non pas besoin de règles
supplémentaires mes besoins que les
règles soient respectées mais
globalement
même s'il y a eu c'est mon appréciation
beaucoup de retard une fois qu'il y a eu
le changement de majorité sur la prise
des décrets d'applications de la loi
grand Guillaume mais de ce point de vue
là je pense que
les textes législatifs et réglementaires
aujourd'hui
constitue un cadre si ce n'est pertinent
dans tous les cas cohérents
merci Monsieur le Ministre d'abord je
voudrais vous remercier pour les
déclarations que vous avez pu avoir
à l'issue des révélations enfin juste
après les révélations hubert-félize
qui montre à quel point vous avez été
complètement
scandalisé par d'abord le lobbying du
Berre son agrégorité le niveau de son
agressivité de son sa détermination
et en main en même temps votre refus que
ce lobbying puisse un moment donné
peser sur sur notre fonctionnement
démocratique quoi
pour revenir sur la question du deal
pour reprendre le terme faut savoir que
ce terme de Deal
c'est pas les journalistes qui
n'avancent c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
parle d'un deal c'est lui dans les
révélations hiberfales ce qui parle d'un
deal entre
la plateforme uber c'est dirigeants et
lui-même
l'arrêt du berpop en échange de
un allègement
des de la réglementation et à ce
moment-là il y a quand même toute une
bataille menée par Hubert depuis le
début comme vous l'avez bien rappelé de
toute façon la stratégie du berz est
d'imposer un état de fait un état de
droit et donc ils ont même y compris
théoriser une la pyramide excusez-moi
l'expression mais la pyramide de merde
il la théorise comme ça c'est ça le
terme la pyramide de merde qui est
comment s'attaquer à l'ensemble des
réglementations des lois et donc c'est
une stratégie offensive pour imposer une
dérégulation du secteur et
partir à la conquête une situation
monopolistique sur sur un secteur et
c'est comme ça que vont procéder pas mal
de d'autres d'autres acteurs de
l'ubérisation ou de la plateforme du
travail
pour revenir à ce qui nous concerne sur
ce deal est-ce que si vous estimez que
le résultat
n'est pas tant qu'on passe de 250 à 7
heures parce que ça de ce point de vue
là on peut se dire bah oui quelle est
l'énorme cadeau mais pour vous on passe
d'une absence d'examen et d'une
formation qui pouvait te donner par des
officines opaques très dépendant du
Berre et donc on pouvait payer
sa licence VTC pour pas cher à coûte 250
euros et sans forcément avoir
véritablement besoin d'une formation
alors que l'examen et ensuite les
conditions d'application qui vont être
plus exigeants sur l'examen finalement
une défavorable à uber est-ce qu'on peut
pas en déduire qu'à un moment donné
Macron a peut-être une intention avec
les dirigeants du Berre d'opérer ce deal
qu'ils ont et qui n'ont pas forcément
réussi à obtenir l'ensemble de leurs
fins est-ce que vous
en tant que ministre des Transports
est-ce que vous avez pu à l'époque avoir
des désaccords avec le ministre de
l'économie sur ce qu'il entendait
ou ce qu'il souhaitait ou ce que le
ministère de l'Économie et du numérique
négociait sur les questions de formation
est-ce que vous étiez je sais pas ce que
des gens dans votre cabinet ont eu des
contacts avec des membres du cabinet de
Monsieur Macron pour pousser plutôt le
dossier dans tel ou tel direction en
fait ce qui est intéressant c'est de
savoir avant l'arrivée de cette
de cette arrêtée qu'elles ont été les
échanges les discussions et qu'elle a
été le rôle d'Emmanuel Macron alors dans
les hubert-faces le nom de Monsieur la
crèche qui était membre du cabinet
d'Emmanuel Macron ressort assez
fréquemment comme un intermédiaire
extrêmement important avec le dirigeants
du maire est-ce qu'il a aussi joint un
rôle dans la suite du du portage des des
intérêts demandés par Hubert dans ces
discussions là
un rapporteur je
ne sais pas et je ne dis pas qu'il y a
pas eu un deal entre Emmanuel Macron et
Hubert la question c'est est-ce que il y
a eu un deal entre Hubert et le
gouvernement la réponse est non voilà
ce que Manuel Macron a dit à Hubert ce
qui semble ressortir ça n'engage que lui
que ces rapports et la qualité de la
relation moi je n'ai pas d'appréciation
à porter et je vous précise que je n'ai
eu aucun contact sur cette question de
la formation avec lui
à ma connaissance personne de mon
cabinet non plus parce que
nous sommes dans la période où on m'a
redonné l'ensemble du dossier
on est dans la créativité on est
attentif non pas aux heures de formation
mais au contenu de l'examen parce que
c'est vrai que la question que se pose
les fonctionnaires qui doivent rédiger
cette nous faire la proposition de
rédaction de cet arrêté c'est en faire
assez ne pas en faire trop et comme on
part de rien on n'a pas on n'a pas de
précédent donc je me souviens de ces
discussions est-ce qu'il faut faire des
épreuves là l'anglais comment quel
niveau qu'est-ce qu'on peut exiger bon
ça ça a été un vrai débat mais c'était
le seul qui a eu sur les heures de
formation et c'est resté au niveau
des administrations et de mon et de mon
ministère je n'ai eu aucun contact avec
avec
Hubert et ou avec Emmanuel Macron
j'ajoute une chose d'ailleurs qui n'a
pas été évoqué
par votre commission me semble jusqu'à
présent dans le dispositif Hubert qui
était quand même très sophistiqué c'est
la filiale inter la filiale interhim TER
qui fait l'objet d'un
vous trouverez quelques articles de
presse là dessus qui venaient compléter
le système c'est quoi la filiale inter
c'est une filiale à 100% de Hubert et
qui était chargé de faire travailler les
chauffeurs VTC dans la période où ils
avaient eu leur agrément mais il n'avait
pas leur inscription c'est-à-dire une
période de 4 ou 5 3 ou 4 ou 5 mois qui
était une période pendant laquelle et
donc il les faisait travailler un peu
comme faisait la comme faisait les
certains chauffeurs de taxi avec leur
avec des des salariés et donc les gens
venaient étaient travaillés pour le
compte de Hubert avec une
autorisation VTC qui appartient à partir
à Hubert cette filiale a dégagée quand
même qui n'avait aucun salarié prenez un
pourcentage sur l'activité des
chauffeurs VTC et avait dégagé je crois
le à peu près quand même 500.000 euros
de bénéfices chaque année il y a eu un
article de presse notamment dans
Mediapart dans ces périodes là qui était
qui est très intéressant sur l'action de
la filiale Inter et qui vient si je veux
dire couronner le tout sur l'oeuvre de
sur l'oeuvre de Hubert
pour que vous oubliez pas la question
même si elle est marquée quelque part je
vais répondre sur le départ de Grégoire
cop de mon de mon cabinet puisque
ça fait l'objet
de communication c'est quelqu'un qui est
et que j'avais connu puisque il faisait
il avait les mêmes fonctions auprès de
moi au ministère des Relations avec le
Parlement
c'est un garçon qui avait fait une
formation d'avocat Sciences Po de droit
européen et qui exerçait au moment où je
viens ministère relation avec le
Parlement comme conseiller juridique de
Que Choisir qui avait choisi d'être dans
une association de consommateurs qui
étaient passionnée par les nouvelles
technologies et qui va réussir c'est pas
facile la presse parlementaire et il va
pendant deux ans être un bon conseiller
et quand je reviens au transport il
vient avec moi
il ne participait à rien les décisions
politiques sur le fond il faisait bien
son travail de communicants et un jour
il est venu me dire qu'il allait partir
et il a lâché le mot Hubert
nos relations se sont arrêtées là
puisque de toute façon à partir du
moment où il avait fait ce choix il
n'était pas fonctionnaire je n'avais
rien à dire et pas à le retenir il est
parti il a travaillé je crois deux ans
chez Hubert il avait cette passion des
nouvelles technologies et donc il
pensait effectivement lui aussi que
c'était les acteurs qui changent le
monde il est parti chez OVH après qui
est quand même les grandes boîtes de
comme conseiller du président et puis
après je crois qu'il est parti un temps
comme chargé de la communication à
l'Olympique de Marseille et aujourd'hui
travaille il travaille dans son propre
cabinet je crois voilà mais il a eu bon
la seule chose que je peux vous dire
puisque ça a été juste je lui ai posé
qu'une question mais comment
dit ils t'ont contacté qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé parce que c'était pas très
étonné qu'ils essayent de Me de
m'affaiblir d'une certaine façon mais
non il m'a dit c'est un cabinet de
chasseur de tête puisque c'est ce qu'on
dit qui est venu me chercher bon je sais
pas poser d'autres questions il est
parti et comme évidemment il y avait la
question de la commission de déontologie
qui a donné un avis favorable qu'il a
respecté scrupuleusement puisque ils
étaient interdiction d'avoir des
contacts pendant trois ans et il a eu
aucun contact avec personne pendant
toute cette période
quand vous dites aucun contact avec
personne tiens donc ni avec vous ni avec
votre cabinet durant la période du
travail pour vous strictement personne
c'était c'était la condition de la
décision prise par la commission de
déontologie et comme c'est quelqu'un de
réglo et de très très scrupuleux ça a
été respecté à ma connaissance par tout
le monde d'accord
et d'ailleurs auparavant
auparavant avant de de rejoindre Hubert
sur quel dossier est-ce qu'à un moment
donné il a pu être amené à travailler
sur des dossiers
liés liée au VTC au conflit d'activité C
ou est-ce qu'il était vraiment sur
d'autres d'autres sujets où est-ce que
sa raison s'habitant en termes de
communication pouvait l'amener à aborder
tous les sujets de fait de votre cabinet
border tous les sujets mais dans la
limite des compétences d'un chargées de
communication et ne participez pas aux
réunions techniques et politiques
que je faisais à l'intérieur de mon
cabinet il est quand même parti assez
tôt puisque là nous on en revient là en
septembre
2014 il part en juin 2015 donc c'est
assez c'est assez rapide voilà après
évidemment il avait connaissance de ce
que je faisais mais il n'a jamais
participé à aucune discussion
sur le fond ni eu de contact avec les
gens de Hubert sur sur ces questions là
préalablement à son départ au titre de
mon cabinet
c'est la question récurrente pour
revenir sur sur les révélations des
hubert-files vous estimez-vous en fait
non seulement que si
j'essaie de vous relire vous dites je
savais qu'Emmanuel Macron était
favorable à Hubert ça correspondait à
son état d'esprit à sa défense de la
start-up nation j'avoue que j'ignorais
que ça avait l'ampleur révélée
aujourd'hui
que ça se traduise par ce lobbying ou
par un mouvement permanent d'influence
institutionnelle au service d'une
entreprise internationale qui a comme
comme principal règle de nos respecter
aucune je dois dire que même moi je
tombe des nues c'est à dire que vous
avez
estimé que
l'ampleur de ce lobbying et de ce lien
et vous parlez même de connivence
que vous découvrez au moment des
révélations hiver files au moment où
vous êtes dans le gouvernement comme lui
vous n'en n'avez pas conscience à ce
niveau là
et vous estimez que par exemple sur la
formation
le lobbying n'a pas gagné et vous n'avez
pas forcément d'éléments à nous donner
sur comment le looming a essayé de peser
vous ne le voyez pas du point de vue de
votre ministère
néanmoins vous dites que
je savais qu'il y avait une initiative
duber derrière certains amendements et
j'ai toujours été en première ligne pour
les faire retoquer mais les textes de
ses amendements étaient ensuite repris
dans des arrêtés des décrets voir en
essayant d'influencer des services
administratifs donc c'était un combat
pratiquement de tous les jours
qu'Emmanuel Macron a mené est-ce que
voilà est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire plus là-dessus
d'abord sur l'appréciation je confirme
mes propos
je connaissais parfaitement les
convictions d'Emmanuel Macron et pas que
sur ce sujet puisque il y a eu d'autres
sujets
bien plus grave qui nous a posé qui
était la privatisation d'ADP puisque
mais l'arbitrage en lui par le Président
de la République était contre la vente
du capital ADP proposait par Emmanuel
Macron auquel je m'étais opposé fort à
un moment dans une note envoyer au
président de la République au Premier
ministre argumentant pourquoi il fallait
pas faire cela donc les relations ont
été franches c'était clair et net
je connaissais les convictions je
connaissais pas les connivences
ça j'ai découvert ça
à la lecture même si j'estime que ça n'a
pas eu de conséquences je peux pas
utiliser utiliser d'autres d'autres
monts
pour pour qualifier ce que ce que j'ai
découvert c'est pour ça que je pense je
le dis à la fin de mon propos liminaire
que il faut peut-être renforcer les
dispositifs sur la transparence et
notamment des activités
gouvernementales
chacun ici qui a pu exercer ok exercera
des responsabilités de ce type savent
bien que la rencontre entre les
responsables publics et les responsables
d'entreprise
c'est même souhaitable pour le bon
fonctionnement
d'un pays d'une nation qui est au
ministère des Transports vous passez
votre temps à recevoir beaucoup de
responsables d'entreprises il peut
parfois pour sauver tel ou tel
implantation où on vous demande
de commander des trains parce que parce
que c'est nécessaire pour qu'on ferme
pas Belfort ou telle usine en Alsace
donc je connais ça par coeur et je vais
pas lui reprocher mais
je pense que les règles c'est parce que
préconisera votre votre commission mais
le faut que tout cela jamais le citoyen
n'est le sentiment que ça puisse se
passer dans l'opacité c'est ça la règle
majeure et sur les amendements
c'est compliqué sur la traçabilité des
amendements
je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse obliger un député qui
dépose un amendement à expliquer d'où il
vient pourquoi
avec le privilège de là j'ai été
rapporteur dans nombre de lois assez
conséquents dans cette maison pendant 25
ans
et notamment le droit du travail droit
de la famille
et la pratique est toujours la même on
reçoit beaucoup de gens
quand vous avez un texte de droit du
travail recevez les syndicats vous
recevez les patrons est-ce que ces gens
arrivent avec des amendements oui bien
sûr mais depuis toujours première fois
j'étais élu en 1988 donc mais c'était
déjà comme ça
mais le travail que vous faites vous
comme rapporteur ou que fait tel ou tel
député parfois
ça rejoint ce que propose tel syndicat
ou telle organisation pourquoi
faudrait-il que votre amendement tout
d'un coup porte le nom de tels syndicats
de tel non ce qu'il faut je pense et ce
que je suggère c'est que ceux qui font
des propositions d'amendement leur
rendent public après chacun pourra voir
ce qui a été repris ce qui a pas été
repris mais la traçabilité l'amendement
il doit rester celui du parlementaire et
après par contre que ceux qui viennent
et qui déposent des propositions
d'amendement ou qui en envoient mais
c'est ça qui doit être public telle
structure professionnelle telle personne
tel groupement fait des propositions
d'amendement et bien ça ça doit être
quelque part accessible pour tout
citoyen notamment probablement sur le
site sur le site de l'Assemblée je pense
que là se trouve la synthèse entre le
respect droit d'amendement qui est quand
même l'essence même de cette maison mais
signé par le parlementaire qu'il assume
et puis il existence de l'exigence j'ai
envie de dire des citoyens de savoir par
qui ça peut être inspiré un moment donné
c'est pas interdit d'avoir des
inspirations communes
monsieur le ministre
on peut dire à ce moment-là que pendant
cette période là
Emmanuel Macron a une par conviction
idéologique et ce sera dit par d'autres
journalistes aussi par une certaine
fascination de la personnalité
particulière de Travis scalanique
certains ont fait des parallèles sur les
stratégies de conquête d'un pouvoir
économique politique
Emmanuel Macron est donc dans des liens
extrêmement forts et avec les lobbys
du Berre dans une opacité la plus totale
mais comme le rapport souvent le
Président on est plutôt dans un rapport
où dans les arbitrages
ministériels en tous les cas c'est ce
que nous disent
parce que nous dire monsieur Cazeneuve
Premier ministre ministre de l'Intérieur
de l'époque et vous même les arbitrages
sont un échec pour Macron et pour Hubert
et pour autant on est aussi dans un
contexte ou alors que le l'idéologie
dominante est très prouber qui par
ailleurs mais le paquet en termes de
études économiste payée dans les
conclusions sont déjà dans le bon de
commande de départ article non signé
mais qui permettent de vanter le modèle
uber enfin tout est fait pour montrer
qu'elle est moderne d'un côté les
archaïques de l'autre et que par
ailleurs face à la problématique de
l'emploi c'est Hubert qui va sauver qui
va sauver la situation donc on est quand
même dans un contexte très très
favorable
les lois qui sont prises
loi thévenou puis Guillaume ne sont pas
appliqués
on a une plateforme qui va user du
beerpop pour en même temps développer
uber qui Hubert est aussi hors la loi
il va y avoir quand même des manquements
de l'État malgré les décisions de
justice enfin prud'hommes ou de justice
sur le travail dissimulé malgré les
problèmes liés à la fiscalité Berne pas
d'impôts en France
uber par ailleurs fait payer la TVA par
s'échauffeurs et l'on n'assume pas la
raison de stabilité
Hubert va être aussi va avoir aussi des
soucis concernant la DGCCRF on voit que
sur tous les dimensions le caractère
hors la loi du père continue et
je dirais plus de 10 ans plus tard le
braquage des lois de la République se
poursuit par cette opérateur par cette
plateforme comme par d'autres donc sur
le long terme même si aujourd'hui on
n'est pas dans le même contexte culturel
idéologique où je pense que beaucoup de
citoyens sont revenus du modèle uber
prenant conscience justement du retour
un peu tâcheron du du
19e siècle et les taxis reprennent un
peu du poil de la bête et ne sont plus
menacés comme avant néanmoins les Louane
sont toujours pas appliquées
et Hubert est-il si inquiété que cela
c'est à dire avec le recul avec le recul
est-ce qu'à un moment donné à l'époque
face au manquement de l'État est-ce que
le poids idéologique du lobby Dube n'a
pas donc pesé sur la capacité que nous
avons pu avoir en tout cas que les
décideurs publics dans leur ensemble ont
pu avoir maloutillé pour pouvoir faire
respecter l'état droit
parce que le
ministre Emmanuel Macron à l'époque
comme volonté
d'essayer de
remettre en cause l'économie de la rente
comme il appelait
et qui va s'attaquer donc à travers la
loi croissance un certain nombre de
questions
les notaires
[Musique]
la création des bus Macron moi je
n'étais pas fermée j'ai soutenu la
création des bus Macron je trouve que
c'était une bonne idée en matière de
complémentarité y compris socialement y
compris d'aménagement d'aménagement du
territoire et aujourd'hui ça a trouvé ça
a trouvé un équilibre
et puis les chauffeurs sont salariés il
y a pas de question de ce point de vue
là
moi je pense que le modèle et j'ai dit
très clairement mais j'étais pas
ministre du Travail à l'époque et il y
avait cette obsession des chiffres de
l'emploi mais que ceux qui posent
problème dans le modèle chez les VTC dès
lors qu'il y a les lois sur le respect
du
de l'occupation du domaine public
notamment et des modalités de prise en
charge des clients c'est le statut des
chauffeurs c'est le statut des
chauffeurs et que c'est là s'il y a une
une victoire puisque vous parlez comme
cela de Hubert globalement
c'est sur ce terrain là et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que
le travail est devant nous puisque la
directive européenne va peut-être venir
faire ce que nous n'avons pas fait
pourquoi on l'a pas fait ça c'est une
autre question collectivement
je pense qu'on a eu tort et mais qui a
pas eu d'initiative à l'époque il faut
dire que la période était quand même
plus qu'un temps dans cette période-là
si vous voulez bien mettre des dates
dont on parle avec les dates des
attentats et de ce qui se passait dans
notre pays préfèrent vous dire que bon y
compris la priorité de l'opinion
publique même s'il est taxi les VTC
étaient très mobilisés et était quand
même ailleurs
donc on peut dire que dans la suite de
ce que vous venez de dire la grande
victoire du Berre et du modèle Hubert a
été d'imposer la possibilité de se
passer du code du travail et de
contourner totalement le code du travail
avec les conséquences aussi sur la
sécurité sociale maintenant le contexte
culturel politique juridique change
puisque
les décisions de justice aboutissent
quasiment toute systématiquement des
requalifications salariés et si le
modèle Hubert se développe dans tout un
tas de secteurs d'activités
en passant par la restauration en
passant par la santé en passant par le
nettoyage en passant même y compris par
des professions juridiques ou
architectes enfin bon il y a pas un
secteur qui aujourd'hui était épargné
par une tentative de plateformisation du
travail et donc de contournement du Code
du travail on a ce débat sur la la
présomption de salariale la directive
européenne aujourd'hui cette la position
de la France ne fait pas l'objet d'un
débat au Parlement qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous en tant que ancien ministre
très attaché cette question à ces
questions sociales et démocratiques
sachant que ce que nous comprenons c'est
que la position de la France est plutôt
à la fois de
faire en sorte que les pays qui auraient
instauré un dialogue social puisse être
exempté d'obligation d'application de de
la loi voir la pression de la France
serait d'augmenter le nombre de critères
à la présomption de salariat ce qu'il a
détricoterait totalement ou bien de
qu'il n'y ait pas de caractère suspensif
c'est à dire que si une plateforme
estime qu'elle fait d'abord qu'elle fait
de l'indépendant et non pas du salariat
et bien qu'elle
puisse garder ses indépendants le temps
que les décisions soient prises bref ce
ne soit pas suspensif voilà que
pensez-vous de tout cela est-ce que
c'est pas aujourd'hui que du coup la
connivence
va à une étape supérieure
bien sûr mais là c'est pas la connivence
c'est la conviction puisque les choses
se font en clair c'est bon c'est la
position c'est la position jusqu'à
présent si j'ai bien compris de la
France dans la dans la négociation elle
est elle est regrettable parce que
je crois que là est vraiment le fond de
l'affaire puisque là on est sur une
question de choix de société il y a eu
la loi Novelli à l'origine sur des
parties d'une bonne idée disons je peux
être auto-entrepreneur mais pour
démarrer une activité peut-être mais la
dérégulation
générale aujourd'hui la remise en cause
du salariat est vraiment me semble-t-il
du point de vue de la cohérence de la
société une question une question
majeure et donc je suis aujourd'hui
favorable est-ce que la position de la
France évolue que ça se fasse d'une
manière transparente parce que
il y a une manière de rendre les choses
irréversibles qui me paraît
difficile à accepter c'est à dire que
quand on crée un espèce de statue
intermédiaire par des petites
dispositions législatives qui vont
ensuite faire dire par la jurisprudence
que il y a chez le législateur la
volonté de quelque chose d'intermédiaire
entre l'indépendant et le salariat et
que par conséquent il n'y a pas de
présomption de salariat je trouve que il
vaut mieux dire les choses clairement
ce qui ne fait pas le gouvernement
français
dans cette période donc je crois que ça
c'est une question majeure
et je veux dire que par rapport à la
question de la construction européenne
il faut vraiment être très attentif à ça
quand vous êtes ministre et transport
vous passez beaucoup de temps à négocier
avec vos partenaires européens puisque
c'est une politique qui est très
intégrée surtout qu'en plus j'avais
compris y compris la pêche et
l'activité de pêche et que
la position de la France était
essentielle dans ces négociations
quand vous êtes à Bruxelles dans ces
négociations la position de la France
compte et donc la France compte en
Europe et que ce que va dire la France
peut être déterminant et que un an des
élections européennes dans un débat que
l'on aura sur quelle Europe on veut
qu'elle est quelle est l'évolution du
vivre ensemble en Europe je crois que
c'est une question fondamentale et
j'espère vraiment que la France aura ce
rendez-vous puisque vous me demandez mon
avis que j'ai l'occasion de le donner je
le fais merci à vous
iez juste une dernière question pour
revenir sa période et puis après vous me
demander à Madame boulot
parler du lobbying du beurre
naturellement monsieur Thévenoud la
semaine dernière nous a dit qu'il avait
ressenti même s'il avait travaillé en
toute indépendance en pression mais
qu'il avait ressenti en tout cas
lobbying intense de tous les acteurs des
VTC comme des taxis lorsque en
particulier de taxi G7 lorsque nous
avons auditionné monsieur Rousselet il
nous a indiqué lui-même avoir été en
lien avec les principaux décideurs
publics qu'il avait accès
personnellement
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
les principaux opérateurs de taxi comme
comme taxi G7
avait aussi fait action de lobbying
auprès des autorités et avait aussi un
accès
facilité ce qui ne veut pas dire que ça
se traduit en petit public
nécessairement mais annexe et facilité
aux principaux dirigeants de l'époque
je pense que la franchise consiste à
répondre oui naturellement il faisait
des démarches
tous azimut auprès des responsables
politiques
si on reprend et j'ai repris pour
regarder vos préparer cette audition mes
agendas de l'époque
il y a eu beaucoup de rencontres mais
dans lesquelles j'ai invité tout le
monde
soit successivement dans des journées
entières les VTC les taxis les
plateformes donc tout le monde était au
thé auditionné d'ailleurs
c'est au cours de ces éditions au moins
les premières je me suis vraiment rendu
compte que que Hubert
il n'avait aucune culture du rapport
avec les autorités publiques ou même
dans le dialogue social
il y a eu un moment donné
un incident assez incroyable il habitude
mener beaucoup de négociations sur les
questions sociales
il y a eu une rencontre entre les
chauffeurs VTC et uber et la personne de
chez Hubert qui négociait le soir même
en voyant en mail mais que n'ont jamais
vu ça pas sur le fond disant mais vous
m'avez mal parlé vous avez fait des
propositions inadmissibles etc qui
montrait bien qu'il y avait aucune
culture de ce qu'est une négociation
sociale et qui montrait bien qu'on était
vraiment dans la confrontation si j'ose
dire de deux mondes
je vous remercie monsieur le président
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre oui je voulais vous
poser une question tout à l'heure vous
avez dit effectivement pouvez se poser
la question de l'indemnisation mais de
mon point de vue
on ne voit pas avec quels font on les
aurait indemnésie pour moi
le fait de des indemniser avec des fonds
publics n'étaient pas cohérents alors je
vais quand même
de ce fait vous poser une autre question
ne pensez-vous pas que
que le fait d'utiliser des fonds publics
soit légitimes puisque au fond c'est une
décision publique qui a
qui a baissé le coût de licence et qui a
et qui a imposé une réglementation qui
dépossédait en fait de leur valeur
patrimoniale les licences et en plus
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que les
citoyens donc attendez étaient
satisfaits de l'ubérisation donc
finalement ça aurait été des fonds
publics mais qui bénéficient au
consommateur donc ne pensez-vous pas
qu'au fond il y avait une certaine
cohérence à utiliser des fonds publics
pour le faire et
et je voulais
les deux les deux solutions étaient
possibles mais
dans la mesure où c'était une question
qui concernait un secteur particulier
dans les priorités budgétaires en
utilisation de l'argent public
j'étais pas très enthousiasme sur cette
idée d'autant que je vous dis il y a un
précédent comment on a indemnisé les les
avouer autrefois bien par une taxe
spéciale sur les sur les frais de
justice c'est un fond qui était alimenté
quelques centimes on pouvait très bien
créer un fond adossé à la Caisse des
dépôts qui payait les licences et puis
pendant X années avoir quelques centimes
parcours ce qui aurait alimenté cela se
aurait été relativement indolore mais
bon
je n'ai eu qu'un succès d'estime dans
cette affaire donc c'est resté comme une
proposition et je conçois la position
des je peux vous demander pourquoi parce
que c'est quand même vraiment un sujet
intéressant et déjà à l'époque avant
même l'arrivée des VTC c'était l'un des
débats autour de la commission Attali
alors là par des fonds publics parce
qu'il y avait pas encore les plateformes
c'est un des sujets aussi dont nous a
parlé Marc Magan qui dit que il regrette
cuber n'est pas
saisi la main tendue d'Emmanuel Macron
qui proposait à uber l'admettre en place
à l'époque une un fonds de compensation
aussi vous vous proposez par une par une
taxe pourquoi on n'a pas pu aboutir à
une solution là dessus
d'abord parce que
si cette solution
avait dû être mis en oeuvre il aurait
fallu qu'elle le soit dans un climat
apaisé je pense que la manière dont
Hubert s'est comporté vis-à-vis des
pouvoirs publics fait qu'on a été du
début jusqu'à la fin dans une situation
très conflictuelle et deuxièmement même
un moment où je dis peut-être que cette
solution mérite d'être regardée je crois
que la décision
des chauffeurs de taxi de ne pas y
répondre favorablement me paraît
compréhensible parce qu'il y a la
question patrimoniale que je n'avais pas
pris en cause et qui est essentiel dans
leur dans leur dans leur démarche quoi
j'ajoute que sur les démarches d'ubair
on en a pas parlé
c'est pas des arguments inventés pour
aujourd'hui puisque j'ai écrit ça dans
un livre
confidentiel mais que vous retrouverez
écrit il y a 4 ans
[Musique]
Hubert
le dernier incident majeur
ça a été le choix de la chambre des
métiers
à mettre un peu d'humour dans notre
rencontre le choix de la chambre des
métiers pour organiser les examens alors
là ça a été un déferlement et compris
les parlementaires recevaient des
lettres disant c'est un scandale c'est
les taxis
qui ont le pouvoir pour organiser les
examens des VTC avec une lettre au
président de la République
signée par les plateformes à
l'initiative du verre
et je comprenais pas ce déferlement
écoutez les chants des métiers les
organisent des concours de cuisinière de
chauffeur de platrier je sais pas
pourquoi il pourrait pas organiser
les concours de VTC
j'ignorais c'est parce que le président
de la Chambre Nationale des Métiers
était chauffeur de taxi
et pour l'humour de notre rencontre vous
regarderez qui c'était puisqu'il est
devenu ministre du gouvernement de
Macron dans les années suivantes c'était
monsieur Griset et c'était lui qui était
l'objet de cette vindique de Hubertz
pour montrer le caractère aussi
totalement déraisonnable et outrancier
et cette bataille là
contre les chambres des métiers a fait
l'objet d'un amendement à l'Assemblée au
Sénat aussi porter à chaque fois inspiré
par Hubert et même d'une espèce de
de limitation du pouvoir législatif dans
un projet d'actes réglementaire c'est à
dire que quand latexte arrive au Conseil
d'État pour le décret d'application le
rapporteur du Conseil d'État vous les
limiter la compétence à 18 mois ce que
m'a fait connaître le haut
fonctionnaires qui ne représentait dans
la préparation du texte autant vous dire
qu'il a eu la réponse et que ça s'est
pas fait mais voilà donc pour bien
montrer quel était le climat quand même
et et
je dis l'énervement pour être poli de
Hubert sur ces questions pas c'est pris
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que
auparavant Hubert avait ses filiales qui
passait la formation et donc il
contrôlait tout je dirais contrôlait
avec voiture noire la voiture à louer
vous parliez de inter pour la période
intermédiaire où vous n'avez pas encore
votre votre carte VTC enfin j'ai tout
été organisé pour qu'il y a un
écosystème parallèle qui échappe à tout
contrôle donc d'abord je pense que
Hubert pouvait s'inquiéter que les taxis
fonctionnent comme eux et donc à la
Chambre des Métiers s'il y avait un
ancien chauffeur de taxi forcément il
serait dans une logique mafieuse
équivalente à celle du modèle Hubert par
miafuse au sens vraiment un écosystème
parallèle quoi illégal
et donc ils avaient une volonté
déterminée de tout
consécuter quoi on est quand même aussi
dans une situation où
de fait que ce soit pour faire respecter
le code du travail pour faire respecter
les obligations sociales d'employeurs
pour faire respecter la fiscalité
les manquements de l'État se poursuivent
à tous les niveaux et le modèle de
l'uberisation s'est développé à plein
d'autres secteurs en partant du modèle
Hubert
sans être plus inquiété que cela donc il
commence à y avoir des décisions de
justice certes mais
selon vous quand on voit le l'ampleur du
développement de l'ubérisation ou les
derniers chiffres sur les créations
d'entreprises bon en vérité c'est une
majorité de création de
micro-entreprises donc on n'est pas dans
une stratégie on crée de l'emploi mais
chacun crée son propre statut précaire
d'auto-entrepreneur quoi donc le mythe
du plein d'emploi à travers cette cette
voie là est en train de s'effondrer face
aux chiffres de la réalité mais en
termes d'intérêt pour le modèle
capitaliste de pouvoir se passer de code
du travail de pouvoir échapper à la
solidarité nationale fiscale et
d'échapper aux obligations de la
Solidarité sociale ce modèle il s'est
bien détendu
est-ce que
est-ce que vous pensez que les
gouvernements si les gouvernements
d'aujourd'hui yadèrent le gouvernement
de l'époque a été pris de cours par
rapport à l'accélération de
développement de ce modèle et face aux
autres problématiques très dramatiques
vous le rappeliez et Monsieur Cazeneuve
le rappeler également le contexte
théorique
d'abord nous sommes au début du
phénomène
il y avait quand même une conscience que
la situation
pouvait pouvait s'aggraver en même temps
la réalité
de dispositif qui permettent la création
d'entreprise
mérite d'être soutenu je suis pas moi
contre ce qui encourage les gens y
compris dans le stade ce que devait être
le statut d'auto-entrepreneur au départ
le problème c'est le détournement le
problème c'est le détournement général
ou généralisé dans des professions
aujourd'hui qui dit des
moniteurs d'auto-école qui soit
auto-entrepreneur ça me paraît quand
même assez stupéfiant mais c'est vous
l'avez dit dans beaucoup de professions
et c'est à ça je crois que il faut que
garder ce que peut être un objectif
partagé sur la création d'entreprise
avec l'utilisation de ce statut pour des
gens qui veulent expérimenter telle ou
telle idée ou telle ou telle passion
mais
c'est pas acceptable qu'on assiste comme
ça spectateurs les pouvoirs publics
espèce de démembrement général du Code
du travail d'autant que bon
quel est le coût à la fin pour la
société de tout ça en termes de perte de
cotisation en termes de situations
sociales qu'il faut bien compenser par
d'autres politiques en termes de
cohésion
je suis depuis toujours très
interrogatif sur cette évolution
merci Monsieur le Ministre et les
derniers points de parler font
par partie à part entière comme vous le
savez de notre commission d'enquête et
effectivement nous aurons à rendre des
recommandations et des conclusions sur
cet aspect là aussi y compris sur les
débats en cours sur la directive
européenne sur lesquels notamment nous
aurons à auditionner un centre de
ministre actuels du gouvernement donc je
vous remercie de de vos propos et de
vous analyses je crois que nous n'avons
plus d'autres questions et puis de toute
façon nous vous avons gardé bien au-delà
de leur initiale en plus à l'heure du
déjeuner donc je vous remercie beaucoup
de votre disponibilité de de vos
réponses si nous avons des questions
complémentaires nous voulons peut-être
parvenir et à l'inverse si vous même
vous voulez nous faire parvenir des des
compléments de réponse ou des
informations n'hésitez pas à nous avons
encore quelques mois de travail devant
nous l'intervalle je vous remercie et je
vous souhaite une excellente journée
monsieur ministre